ouais l'achat pour le premier voyage le
temps d'un été lagarde propres vies
notamment grâce à de résine qui
transporte 15 voyageurs par heure
le conducteur est assisté par un agent
d'accompagnement ancien cheminot qui
fait office des guides bénévoles
la particularité de cette section c'est
qu'elle est restée dans son jus
je dirais si vous regardez
il ya cent ans était exactement la même
chose
vous allez retrouver les mêmes passages
à niveau les mêmes maisons
au niveau de la voix c'est pareil c'est
d'origine le rails les traverses le
ballast donc c'est ce qui est
intéressant
la balade dure quatre kilomètres jusqu
au silo de montoir vitesse maximale 30
km/heure sur des voies rester dans leur
jus comme la draisine et qu'ils aient
pour la sncf de 1968 aux années 90 la
draisine servait à emmener des cheminots
qu'on a fait des cantonniers c'est à
dire qu'il travaillait sur la voie et
donc on les a menées pour faire la
petite la petite maintenance empreinte
qu'on faisait le trajet en train donc
c'était la draisine c'est un train de
voyageurs mais réservé aux cheminots aux
employés la promenade les pas très long
d'une petite demi heure le temps de
découvrir les paysages et le patrimoine
local c'est sympa visiter les enfants
ils adorent donc agréable c'est agréable
ce n'est qu'en retour on va dire un
petit peu vers verra pas ses racines en
sarthe finalement sympathique bonne
occasion de visiter un petit peu la
région autrement qu'en voiture
pour ceux qui seraient un peu frustré
par la durée du voyage le train
touristique sillonnent sur les anciennes
voies du val de loire quatre jours par
semaine pendant trois heures le temps
d'une déconnexion totale mais en
autorail cette fois